so I was reading that it took you 18
months to finish the first draft of the
script so I was wondering is that just
because you are super busy or was there
a specific plot point that you found
most challenging to crack that's an
inaccuracy is 8 months 8 months good to
know yeah that seemed and now that seems
fast all right and I do tend to write
pretty fast so it was 8 months I made
either me mumbling or someone was
hearing my words but then after I did
that pass is its constant like whittling
and fine tuning and tweaking I'm always
trying to find the even the more truth
in the story so I'm always tweaking it
up until even when I'm filming what
would you say is the biggest change from
first draft to finish feature whether
it's something that needed a little more
working in the script phase or maybe a
happy magic incident on set the biggest
change was the race of a particular
person that has to do with the ending
that's what I say I can't wait okay no
good way that was a thing that we got a
suggestion from a phenomenal DP Bradford
Young who read it and we were thinking
it was gonna shoot it he ultimately did
not but he's a friend of the family and
we loved him and he was like what if
this person were black that that meets
them at their car after they waked up
okay so I was like huh
I was like I gotta sit with that one but
I did and I thought about it nothing
else that makes it more complex it makes
it more interesting
no I could've gotten I can't believe you
were able to explain that to me and I
knew exactly what you were talking about
we didn't spoil anything for any well
good now everyone can enjoy that I'm
nice nice I wanted to ask you a little
bit about not using names in the script
too and using more more descriptors to
convey your characters in the script is
that something that applies to Queen and
slims specifically for you or do you
think that's something that could help
screenwriting in general well it's a
thing I'm doing in this other script
that I wrote to that's other feature
what my second feature after this and is
I don't know it's at space I'm in you
know I just kind of feel like people
don't use names in conversation and also
too I feel like we are each other so
it's an algorithm like if when you
it's interesting cuz like you look at
iconic characters like say Thalmann
Louise people identify with them what
they identify with Louise but and that's
fine those are their names it's totally
cool but to me I really wanted these
people to represent black people so I
was like you can give them your name
they could be you you know and queenís
logo could be any one of us and and I
really wanted to play with that
convention and when you do find out
their names it's it's very it's on
purpose and it's very intentional in the
film and some people maybe they didn't
realize like oh I didn't even know that
I didn't know I certainly did it until
the very end and then for me I mean it
hit me like a truck when I first heard
it usually a name of a character doesn't
have that kind of weight I really
appreciate thank you I'm glad it worked
I mean it was definitely a risk I knew
that when I was writing it but I'm just
grateful that Molina never blinked about
it she was like okay and then also there
was never a harvey keitel in our film
there's no copy that you know
sympathizes with the criminal but it has
to bring them to do that and but again
no one they were like okay and so we
take some risks in the movie as well and
you know we don't you never know how
critics are gonna respond to that or
they but we just I didn't care I thought
what did you have been different it's
good to take risks it makes for a more
interesting conversation I'm curious
though you are an emmy-winning writer
this is your first feature film you're
ready said you're working on your second
one now is there anything about this
specific storytelling format and writing
for it that surprised you uh it is a
heavyweight it is you know I'm used to
the 30 pages you know 60 pages and I
think it is this is a marathon you know
it takes a lot more stamina you know and
it can be daunting you know when I'm
doing a new pass on the freaking feature
because I'm going through different
things and I can't and I'm a big person
I still have all my stuff up on a wall
and I'm looking at thing out of actual
map here and I've got the character arcs
there and all that kind of stuff and I'm
just trying to keep track of everything
and making sure I call back to this in
this way there's that and there are a
couple things that kind of match like
where goddess says one of the things
that makes her feel happy is when a girl
kisses her on the forehead and then you
have slim kissing clean on the forehead
in the car or the horse seen through the
beautiful white horse is so peaceful and
the ride
oh wow there's something there's
something about that there's something
about someone just like taking a step
back and recognizing like the simplest
thing in their life that makes them
happy or just an act of human kindness
that I don't know it always just touches
me I just and I think it was also
humanizing those people in that house or
you can easily look at them and go you
know you can give the judgement and I
was about how can I humanize them and so
when you hear the things that make her
happy somebody and the audience is like
a lot like nice robes of hotels you know
I like this and you kind of relate to it
okay that you ordinarily might have
judged and for me to think of the little
things in your life you should
appreciate what room